now in 2015
he became an outspoken voice for the
transgender community
a year later he was praised for being
the first american to be legally
recognized as what they call non-binary
jamie shupe was the darling of the lgbtq
world
instead of recognizing though a
desperate cry for help
doctors judges and activists used him to
advance their cause he says they took
advantage of his vulnerability as an
army veteran suffering
from ptsd to break barriers shupe will
never be the same joining me now to tell
his story and it's shocking
is jamie shoot himself jamie thank you
for being here it takes a lot of courage
to be here
um you say the transgender community
has not only turned their backs on you
but are now attacking you
what happened that's that's correct
laura
the minute you denounce anything
transgenderism-wise
you're automatically an outcast for
example i support presidents trump's
president trump's ban on transgender
military service
i do not agree with transitioning
children or
transgender surgeries i'm against all of
this
now did you take the hormones and start
doing all that
and you didn't obviously do surgery i
guess but you did start taking
estrogen and progesterone what did you
do
yes i took estrogen and progesterone i
now have
irreversible breast growth i had a
number of health complications from this
i have now had bone density problems
i've had kidney problems and at one
point my mental health was so
destabilized by the hormones that i had
two stays in a psychiatric ward because
of it
do you think this kind of push is being
used
broadly more broadly uh you hear from i
hear from a lot of people
and you see a lot of examples heritage
foundation did a big panel
of feminists who are actually really
upset by this because
they think people are being kind of
pushed into
this you know this you know this kind of
view of of life and transgenderism
before they really kind of know who they
are um or is that
wrong
no that's that's completely correct um i
my head is off to the heritage
foundation because it's
really the only place that people such
as myself and these radical feminists
are getting a voice
we've been completely silenced by by the
left
you know as you said i was previously a
you know transgender media darling
and now the new york times doesn't want
to talk about me anymore or even
acknowledge that i exist
because i no longer support this stuff
yes the
the conservatives are to be commended
for what they're doing to help us to
help children
have you talked to other people who
began transitioning
and maybe even did transition have they
reached out to you
if they have regrets do they look look
to you for advice or
just to share a story
yes laura i regret is unfortunately is
very common but uh but again you know
the the media doesn't want to talk about
these surgeries that go wrong
in in the host of health complications
and it's really wrong to even call this
transition because
gender identity is is essentially it's
legal fiction
you know first they claimed that i was a
woman and then they claimed that i was a
combination of male and female and and
everybody
went along with this but as i said it's
nothing but legal fiction
sergeant uh we wish you the best i know
it's incredible it sounds incredibly
traumatic and difficult and i hope
you'll stay in touch with us
um and we'll certainly stay in touch
with you thank you so much
thank you too laura absolutely